[Music]
finland and sweden have formally applied
to be the 31st and 32nd countries to
join nato which could allow the alliance
to fill a large gap on the map near
russia in an increasingly volatile part
of the world
but turkey a key nato member that also
sits in a strategically important
location
blocked the start of initial membership
talks for the two countries
turkey's president has said that
allowing the nordic nations to join nato
would deprive the security organization
of security his comments took western
allies by surprise and since all 30 nato
countries have to approve the addition
of any new members turkey's position has
set off a diplomatic scramble so let's
take a look at what's behind turkey's
objections and what turkey might be
seeking in order to get on board with
this historic nato expansion
first let's look at what turkey has been
saying by many measures sweden and
finland are considered some of the
world's safest countries but turkish
president recep tayyip erdogan has
called them a complete hotbed of
terrorism and he alleges that the
countries particularly sweden are
harboring terrorists who threaten
turkey's national security his main
complaint here is about the pkk or the
kurdistan workers party which has been
fighting for autonomy and is mainly
present in turkey syria iraq and iran
the pkk has been waging an insurgency
against turkey for decades and the
fighting has left tens of thousands of
people dead it has been designated a
terrorist organization not just by
turkey but by the us and the european
union though the group says it's
fighting for an autonomous kurdish
homeland and denies being a terrorist
organization so here's why this is
coming up now turkey alleges that the
governments of sweden and finland are
supporting the pkk even though those
governments technically consider it a
terrorist organization and turkey's
state-run media have been running
stories like this in recent days
alleging that swedish-made weapons have
ended up in the hands of pkk fighters
sweden which is home to thousands of
kurds with varying political views has
accused turkey of spreading
disinformation erdogan also alleges that
sweden and finland are harboring
gulenists or followers of fethullah
gulen he's a muslim cleric living in the
u.s and turkey accuses him of being
behind an attempted military coup that
stunned the world in 2016.
glenn has denied the allegations to
better understand turkey's position on
all of this i called osla aiden
toshbosch a turkish journalist turned
senior fellow at the european council on
foreign relations for a number of years
now uh turks have been feeling
entirely abandoned that they're
surrounded by enemies geographically but
also that their
allies are not their friends and this
sentiment goes back to the failed coup
attempt of 2016.
it's partly
real partly paranoia a mixture of
history and recent events but the net
result is a government that feels it has
to push back osla says that erdogan's
issue regarding these terrorists and
alleged terrorists goes beyond just
finland and sweden one particular source
of frustration is that for years the u.s
and other western nations have been
partnered with kurdish militants in
syria including an offshoot of the pkk
in order to fight isis turkey considers
these fighters to be terrorists and
after turkey launched an offensive
against kurdish fighters in syria in
2019 some european countries punished
turkey by restricting arms exports to
the country what is not clear is how
much of this is about sweden
and how much of this is about broader
set of grievances towards
allies plus osla points out that next
year is an election year in turkey and
erdogan is under immense pressure due to
turkey's faltering economy that domestic
pressure might be motivating erdogan to
secure concessions from the west
so what might those concessions be
for one turkey is pressuring finland and
sweden to crack down on any media
organizations and individuals allegedly
linked to the pkk and it's seeking the
extradition of suspected militants from
sweden erdogan also wants finland and
sweden to drop their restrictions on
arms exports to turkey beyond the pkk
issue erdogan could try to use his
leverage to get approval to buy f-16
fighter jets from the u.s and to get
turkey back into the u.s led f-35
fighter jet program the u.s kicked
turkey out of the program after turkey
bought missile systems from russia in
2019. the reality is turkish president
is not going to let this crisis go
without getting something in return
so back to finland and sweden officials
from both countries have acknowledged
turkey's concerns we take terrorism
seriously we condemn terrorism in all
its forms
and we are actively engaged in combating
it
we are right now having a dialogue with
all nato member countries including
turkey analysts say finland is mostly
caught in the crossfire when it comes to
turkey's allegations but in sweden where
there are six kurdish members of
parliament and sympathy for the kurdish
cause runs deep officials could face a
difficult balancing act in finding
common ground with turkey a big nato
summit is scheduled for the end of june
so leaders and diplomats are facing
pressure to get turkey on board and
resolve the issue before then we are
determined to work through all issues
and reach rapid conclusions despite the
holdup nato leaders say they expect
turkey to come around on voting yes to a
historic nato expansion an expansion
prompted by russia's war in ukraine to
learn more about how putin's war has
strengthened nato in other ways check
out this video thanks for watching
[Music]